speaking of the gays we actually have
some good gay news uh the dean of the
washington national cathedral his name
is gary hall he is calling homophobia a
sin not homosexuality homophobia a sin
in a sermon on sunday he said this
homophobia is a sin heterosexism is a
sin shaming people for who they love is
a sin shaming people because their
gender identity doesn't fit neatly into
your sense of what it should be is a sin
only when all churches say that clearly
and boldly and courageously will our
lgbt youth be free to grow up in a
culture that totally embraces them fully
as they are
i mean obviously to me this seems pretty
great and i think we have to give some
props to uh to the pope he seems to be
turning things around in the in the
religious gay sphere is that a that's a
club i think um this is all good right
amazing do we have any negative thing
attached to this what's it ever pretty
great no
you could be cynical i suppose uh you
know and suggest that he's looking out
on sundays at the flock uh these are
this is the national cathedral so these
are episcopalians yeah and looking out
there and saying uh you know where have
all the 20 and 30 year olds gone they're
tired of the gay hate but i think you're
right dave i think it's i think the pope
sort of opened things up and the very
reverend
the very yeah so can you explain what
the very is because they call him here
they're very very rapid he's just super
reverend yeah
that's extra yeah everything he does is
reverend he's very reverend yes uh no
it's a i get term given by the a lot of
religions use it the episcopal's
episcopalians give it to just senior
priests so right he's an important dude
um and a very important dude um and i
think he heard the pope and i think he
thought
i don't want to be left off this he
probably thought it for years but you
can't say it or you risk the death of
your own career uh of course the the
episcopalians here have been split
for a long time because they they they
made gene robinson i think was his name
in connecticut a bishop he was openly
gay uh for which caused this huge split
between conservative episcopalians and
uh
and and more forward-thinking people so
but i think he heard the pope and he
thought i don't want to be left out this
is the pope even though it's a different
religion has
opened up a window where i think i can
say this yeah now the pope obviously
he's roman catholic so he doesn't
directly affect the episcopalians but it
all sort of yeah that's all sort of fits
like we don't want it all of a sudden
like one thing episcopalians had is
maybe we're maybe we're not as
conservative as the catholics now like
hold on yeah exactly what can we do to
give the pope and and the very reverend
gary hall what can we do to give them
props because i think for the lgbt
community if if you don't step up and
acknowledge when things are actually
changing then they won't change exactly
no i think this is so wonderful
especially when you have like these
leaders that people look up to and they
and they really get all their
knowledge almost from these people yeah
certainly not the bible because
i don't know i everyone would be horror
still yeah so
yeah i think it's great i don't know how
we give props other than uh talking
about it tweeting about it
retweeting the pope i guess retweet the
poem one thing that you could possibly
do so how much further how much further
do we have to go here because if if
religion is finally coming around on the
gay thing and the supreme court's made
some decisions and things are really
happening here and really all over the
world how much further until this is
just completely out of the public
discourse let's deal with america first
like is there a chance that one of the
gop guys in 2016 you think is going to
jump on board because because this is
sort of passed by right i hope so
because i feel like i feel like most
people are i feel like most of these
guys are but they just change their
political views to match the people that
they're that they're running for and i
feel like that's just so stupid why
can't we have like a platform someone on
a platform that stands for everything
like stands for the people what are they
great people
that was essentially about like
whether somebody wanted responsible
regulation yeah and then someone wanted
a little bit more and that we debated a
high tax rate of like whether it should
be 31 or 27. like that was an actual
debate we had in this country yeah um
but we'll get to that
coming down but you know yeah i think in
2016 there's a possibility because
you're already looking at um
you know you wonder whether is chris
christie you know he's roman catholic
and maybe he
he has chris christie not doesn't engage
in hostile anti-gay talk correct i'm not
100 percent sure that he's not for gay
marriage but he's very bizarre in jersey
because it seems like the rest of the
state is and he is challenging the new
jersey supreme court's decision right
but he doesn't that's kind of it is but
he doesn't engage in he is engaged in
the rhetoric so i mean it might not be
such a huge stretch if like what the
pope said influenced him and he said
look i'm against gay marriage but i i
this is but it's 78th on my list of
things that i care about yeah i think
it's maybe because a fat guy doesn't
want to make gay jokes it just makes you
you know what i mean it's too easy to
make them yeah so i i will say that any
time a major religion uh sort of starts
coming out and lets uh somebody off the
hook uh in this to speak oddly of it but
he says you know what maybe we should
ease up on the gays uh that basically
means that it's bad for the jews yeah
because
you got a place for that
i guess we'll just you know what we'll
just go back to hate the jews yeah know
that good old-fashioned date that always
works everybody loves that yeah so last
uh last thought on this so what's that
if the gays get full equality then uh
what's next and then everything's normal
and cool right
answer it for all the gays well i mean
i don't know i just wish that people
would separate this from politics and
from religion in general
so hopefully it just it just becomes
normal like it is normal so why can't
people just like let it be normal i
don't know remember john huntsman ran in
2012. i mean again nobody voted for it
but i mean
yeah of course because he was insane
yeah yeah well he used to stand up there
at the debates and be like i'm saying is
anyone paying attention to this right
because he was kind of he was sort of
decently scummy kind of pro gay and he's
since the election has come out even
more so hey guys the reuben report is
brought to you by coupon.com you can get
up to 75
off pet toys choose all kinds of treats
and more the link is right down below
click it and use code rr for 20 off your
first purchase